Tom Cruise he shocks the convention
making a surprise appearance that
literally blew everybody away and
maverick did not come empty-handed this
is what we've all been waiting to see
the first scenes from the Top Gun sequel
I feeling that loving feeling
34 years ago I made a movie in San Diego
right here I actually shot across the
street this is our very first trailer
you are the first people in the world to
see
the 57 year old Top Gun himself
surprised everyone today walking on
stage to introduce the film's trailer
obviously it's it's for real so the
flying you know we're working with the
Navy the flying you see in these
pictures
everything is real the moment this shot
played the entire room erupted in cheers
Tom speeding on his motorcycle engaged
in the dogfight and our favorite he
recreated the iconic volleyball scene
it's one of life's mysteries sir secrets
how they made Top Gun maps aerial
footages is an intro Tom Cruise style
the movie is making Hollywood history
you're using some technology on this
that is never never before seen I was
shooting the movie in the 6k even
a-listers can't wait to see maverick
back in action after the trailer dropped
Chris Pratt we did take my money the end
is inevitable maverick maybe so sorry
but not today
[Music]